quincy avery who's quincy avery you ask
he's the personal quarterback coach of
texans starter desean watson who wants
out of houston the tweet from quincy
avery what's the criteria for a
quarterback asking to get traded then
actually getting traded
asking for a friend oh oh yes yes he was
asking for a friend and his friend is
deshawn watson look we've seen two
quarterbacks who wanted trades get them
so far matthew stafford gets his trade
out of detroit carson wentz gets his
trade out of philadelphia deshawn watson
still waiting and by all appearances
we'll continue to keep waiting shireen
there was a story in the athletic today
that takes a look at how things went
sideways between deshaun watson and the
houston texans and it goes back to the
andre hopkins trade which he found out
about on social media and then when he
was negotiating his contract bill
o'brien told him he'd have a seat at the
table for the direction of the team and
that all fell apart and they fired bill
o'brien and made desean watson think
what's the direction of this team he
made his comments at the end of the
season about a changing culture that's
reportedly a sign that he wanted jack
east to be gone easter b has only gotten
stronger and more powerful and then they
disregard deshaun watson's input for
coach and gm even though they told him
he'd have a seat at the table for that
that's led to the point where we are
right now where he wants out and
this this dawned on me when i was
writing the item earlier today
if they're into
reshaping the culture in houston and you
have a guy who's saying
i don't want to be part of this culture
why in the world do you want to keep him
that's what i can't figure out
i get why they want to keep him mike i
mean you look at what he's done in
houston he led the league in passing
yards last season he has a 10.94 million
base salary this year and i know it goes
up in 2022 with the 35 million dollar
cap hit but that's still reasonable for
a guy you know is a franchise
quarterback these guys don't grow on
trees they found their franchise
quarterback you think about all the guys
they went through and the ways they
tried to get him from matt shobb to
david carr drafting him number one
overall i mean they went through all
these quarterbacks and they finally
seemingly have found their franchise
quarterback he has a franchise
quarterback i think we'd all agree with
that and now he says he wants out but it
seems to me mike
that
this is an owner who has picked jack
easter b
over deshaun watson that's just the way
it feels to me from from the outside
because
by all appearances desean watson is one
of many players but your most important
player who wants to see jack easter be
gone
and yet he's not gone he's still there
and obviously has a big role and a big
hand in this organization and unless and
until jack easter b is gone i don't know
how this franchise really moves forward
and changes that culture that both j.j
watt and deshawn watson talk about and
this is a team just a couple years ago
that we thought was on the verge of a
super bowl championship with all the
great players that they had on their
team
not anymore they're a long long way mike
from from getting to the mountaintop
with or without desean watson which is
one of the reasons you think maybe they
should trade him and hit that reset
button
well and i i think that the biggest
problem right now for the texans is they
don't know how to properly figure out
what's in their best interest obviously
picking watson over easter bee
is in their best interest but cal mcnair
refuses to do it easter bee has some
kind of hold on cal mcnair
or or or we can't have the inmates
running the prison i keep coming back to
the catchphrase from the late bob mcnair
that was uttered in conjunction with the
ongoing discussions at the time over the
national anthem
that that to me
feels like the ultimate source of
everything that the texans are doing
saying not saying feeling or not feeling
as it relates to sean watson you just
work here
you don't tell us how to run our
business
we decide how to run our business you
don't like jack easter be too bad you're
here to play football we'll worry about
who's working in the front office you
want somebody else to be hired for the
coach
coaching position too bad that's our
decision to make now they made a mistake
by making him think
that that he would have input and see
that's where they've screwed up
you have to have a relationship with
your employee where you communicate
effectively where you let him know you
you know his relationship with the andre
hopkins you don't let him find out on
social media that deandre hopkins has
been traded you make a phone call hey
deshaun we just want to let you know
what's going down here and here's why
we're doing it and we're doing it we
didn't want you to find out on social
media how dumb is that
to not reach out to the most important
employee in your organization with a
five minute phone call it shows that
you're either stupid or you're
inconsiderate
either way either way it's enough when
enough of those things happen for the
guy to say i want out and i understand
why he wants out and i don't know
whether or not the texans are going to
realize it's in their best interest to
shop him now and maximize the return
and then
uh move forward rather than being
stubborn and creating a big fight and
ultimately getting less for deshaun
watson when they inevitably let him go
because he's decided he wants out the
only question is when it's going to
happen and what they're going to get in
return for
well mike and it just feels like they
have no plan right they they've now
drawn this line in the sand and said we
are not trading deshaun watson he'll
come to a census he'll report he's not
going to hold out he's not going to
retire
and then what do you do if he does hold
out what if you do if he holds out in
training camp and then you say okay he's
coming back for the start of the season
you get to week one he's not there what
do you do what's your plan this just
looks like the team a team that has no
plan and if you think you're going to
trade deshaun watson at that point and
get anything of value form
like what you could get right now you're
just not so at that point then you are
probably tied to him at least until the
trade deadline but i just don't know
that you can maximize what you can get
for him like you can right now like you
can before the draft happens where
you're getting draft picks this year
next year the year after however long
however many draft picks that entails
and we all think it entails a lot of
draft picks and probably some players
too maybe the biggest trade since the
herschel walker trade in nfl history but
they'll get a lot from deshaun watson if
they move on him between now and the
draft if they wait like i think they're
going to wait
they're either not going to have him and
he's going to sit out the whole entire
year and they're not going to trade him
or they're going to trade him during the
season or or right before the season
starts and not get what they could get
right now i just don't see a good plan
in place and i see this organization
screwing it up as it stands right now
and it doesn't surprise me at all and
and folks if you want to understand
what this team currently is about go to
youtube find the videos of jack easter b
under the guise of preaching
engaging in stand-up comedy i mean this
guy is so awkward that even michael
scott says man that guy's a little bit
awkward so i it's i if you
if you
uh want to understand again just what
just because this is the guy who's
whispering in cal mcnair's ear this is
the guy
who is
uh setting the decisions and creating
the culture and helping cal mcnair
decide what he should and shouldn't do
and i just think they're completely
misreading it they completely
misunderstand what it's going to take to
make desean watson happy and it's too
late to try to turn it around that's the
other thing they don't ever understand
so for the same reason that they didn't
realize maybe a phone call to desean
watson would be helpful
when they were trading down to ray
hopkins they don't understand that it's
too late to try to fix it now and just
standing back and saying he'll come
around he'll be fine he loves football
too much to sit out and then when he
sits out like oh well we didn't see that
coming and and i think that's where
where this is going to go and it's
unfortunate for deshawn watson but by
all indications he's dug in he doesn't
care if he has to pay back money he'll
pay back money because eventually he's
going to play football again and it's
going to be most likely for somebody
else and if he has to sit out a full
year to prove it i feel like he's got
got himself in the state of mind shireen
that he's willing to do it and uh
it's a shame because this is a guy who
needs to be on the football field he's
one of the best players in the nfl the
game's best interest isn't served by
deshaun watson not being on the field
for someone
well mike and i think that it's time or
is going to soon come a time when
deshawn watson is going to have to pick
up the phone he's going to have to talk
the houston texans himself not through
his agent he's going to have to talk to
them and i also think it's going to come
time for him to come out publicly
have a press conference multiple pro
however whatever you do but talk
publicly and state your case why you
want out and i look i'm not reporting
the texans have to understand this so if
he wants that trade and he wants it now
rather than later where it gets that
point he's holding out he's going to
have to talk to somebody mike and lay
out exactly what he wants and why he's
not showing up for the texans otherwise
this is going to drag out until training
camp and into the season in however long
because the texans aren't going to
change their mind but if he starts the
public campaign of
i want out i could see this speeding
things up mike
yeah that is the one missing ingredient
in this so far and
i don't think deshawn watson is wired to
go public that way the item in the
athletics says that he has a very
deliberately stoic demeanor
that was inspired by witnessing his
mother's battle with cancer and how she
handled the adversity he prides himself
on not getting upset on not showing his
emotion and i think he believes that
this is something that can be resolved
without having create a public fight
that he doesn't want to have to take it
to that point now he could decide at
some point that's his only option i've
done everything i can i've been as
patient as i can be i tried to handle
this professionally i tried to handle
this discreetly i tried to handle this
quietly and they have said no to me at
every turn and you're right at some
point he and his agent david mulligan
need to have a plan for him to do a sit
down with someone who can ask him all
the appropriate questions and some tough
questions
but it gives him an opportunity to say
in his own voice
i do not want to play for the texans and
i love the people in houston
i i enjoy and appreciate my time there
but given where the organization
currently is it's in my best interest
and in the team's best interest for us
to separate and it's clear that sean
watson still has a strong affinity for
the folks in houston aaron wilson in the
chronicle
pointing out today that deshawn watson
provided meals to houston police
officers to help those in need
during this arctic black that is blast
that has ravaged the city and the state
so uh you know deshaw look deshawn
watson has always been like that um and
and he's always been looking to help and
he's always been a great member of the
organization and a great member of the
community but
that's what makes it so unfortunate that
the texans so badly misread the
relationship so badly misplayed the
relationship to get to the point where
this guy wants out you should never let
it get to the point where your franchise
quarterback one of the best in the game
conscientiously decides i don't want to
play for this team anymore that's the
tragedy for the texans that it got to
this point and now that it's there they
just need to accept it and make the best
decisions moving forward
and you know the great thing about it
from deshaun watson's standpoint i have
friends and family who are seasoned
tickets holder there
they already believe that deshaun watson
is gone that that ship has sailed the
bridge has been burned down he's not
coming back they don't blame deshaun
watson they blame jack easterby they
blame cal mcnair and that's how it's
going to be mike no one in houston is
going to blame deshaun watson for this
when he does get traded and i think we
both believe he will eventually get
traded whenever that happens but at some
point he will get traded they are not
going to blame deshaun watson for this
they are going to blame ownership for
this
i continue to be fascinated by the
reality these multi-billion dollar
football operations with so many
resources and so much time and so much
effort and expertise devoted to crafting
the best possible football team
ultimately
is is held
and run by a monarchy and the the keys
get handed to this family member or that
family member with no guarantee
whatsoever that the person who inherits
the ability to run the organization
knows what he or she is doing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports